elle est elle était contente du rendu ou
pas elle a tout validé elle a tout
valide elle a tout vu
mais la même rajouter certains propos à
son interview d'accord les questions que
j'aurais dû lui poser que j'ai oublié de
lui poser
et elle a tout elle assume tout et je
trouve ça très courageux alors il y a
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il était pas content
il a pas alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon il
était d'accord pour aller dans Playboy
ah oui
si tu nous écoutes encore envoyé un sms
tout à l'heure on attend ta réponse
ainsi que ah non sans déconner
[Rires]
dans un conflit social
le plus grand qu'on ait vu de l'histoire
de ce pays depuis 50 ans et il lance
comme ça toutes sortes de petits
trucs de diversion alors monsieur dusoft
vient dire que dire qu'il est homosexuel
donc bon très bientôt tout le monde s'en
fout elle elle va dans ce journal et
c'est une provoque pour que vous me
posiez la question moi j'ai pas envie de
perdre mon temps avec elle le président
de la République va dans Pif alors je
suppose qu'il doit y avoir Pif Gadget
cette semaine avec une petite matraque
ou une grenade lacrymogène enfin tout ça
c'est une sorte de distraction par
rapport au sujet central alors attends
parce que là j'ai vu c'est alors non
mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc c'est quoi
l'histoire parce que c'est vrai qu'il a
failli le faire ah oui il a failli le
faire l'été dernier de faire l'interview
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon au dernier moment
il nous a planté et c'est sur
normalement
parti remise je vais encore envoyer un
SMS cet après-midi Jean-Luc j'attends ta
réponse
bien sûr non on a un peu d'illustration
bah bien sûr l'hypocrisie elle a raison
plein dedans c'est comme Marlène
Schiappa elle est venue ici la première
après tout le monde a voulu voir et tout
le monde vient bien sûr oui Casta Lee
parce que juste ça fait juste c'est pour
tout juste pour la pour le cacher il
faut bien que je parle rien
juste pour toutes les autres que tu as
évoqué alors il fait une interview dans
Elle ou dans le monde personnellement on
aurait parlé donc elle a pris
effectivement un média toi tu as été
certaine qu'il y aura un vrai écho donc
c'est parfaitement réussi
que n'importe quel autre magasin donc
c'est très bien joué
merci c'est bien résumé pour résumer en
fait
c'est non voilà c'est 68 % donc 32 % oui
je savais pas qu'il allait avoir autant
de bruit
68% de Macron et on associe du coup
là ça parle là c'est voilà et puis bon
lui je crois qu'il a fait lui il a il a
il vous avait fait le boulot je pense
que les gens vous ont kiffé